[music]
Hey, hey, hey.
Are you?
[music]
You can feel [music]
>> [music]
[music]
>> Hey.
Hey. Hey.
Christian.
[music]
Hey
>> [music]
[music]
>> Good evening.
Welcome.
Whether this is your first time or your
first time in a long time, we're glad
that you're joining with us this
evening.
Yeah, we can stand up if you want.
My name is Cat and my pronouns are she
and her.
We know that sometimes coming into a
church setting can be a little anxious,
make you a little anxious. We have an
accessibility bucket right over there in
the doorway um on the table.
And if uh we have coloring sheets and
earplugs
and fidget
spinner things,
help yourself.
These candles
are a sign of the presence of Christ.
among us fully human
and fully divine.
And now
as we call to worship,
we [music] exit the kingdom of noise,
hurry,
and productivity.
And now we enter the kingdom of silence.
stillness
and grace.
Now we enter sacred space,
a space [music] for prayer,
for worship,
adoration,
a space
to encounter Christ,
revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation.
May the unforced
rhythms of grace find you
and mend your heart. May we all come
home.
Thank you, Cat. If you are bodily
[music] able and you would like to stand
with us, we're going to get started with
worship tonight. Um we are so glad that
[music] you guys are here and hope that
you feel welcome to interact with this
time. um as freely as [music] you would
as you would feel comfortable. Um sing
along with us if you don't know the
words. We'll try to have them up on the
screens for [music] you. Um but more
than anything, I hope that in your
spirit, you're able to sense a
connection with this [music] God who is
good. This God who is love, who is a
lamp to our feet, and a light to our
path tonight.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Where can we run? [singing]
Where [music] can we hide?
that you will not find
us. [music]
In the deepest of depths
[music and singing]
and the highest of heights,
your love it chases
us.
[music]
No matter where [singing] we've been,
no matter what we've done,
you can escape
your love. [singing and music]
Oh,
and we [music and singing] will never
see the end. We will never see [singing]
the end
of your goodness.
We [singing] will never [music] see the
end. We will never see the end
of your goodness.
[music]
Though we pass through the
[singing and music] fire or we pass
through the flood,
you will [music and singing] be with
us.
Though we [music and singing] walk
through the valley of the darkest of
night, [singing]
[music]
>> your love will be
our [singing]
light.
But when we are in plenty and we
[singing and music] are in want,
you will always be
enough.
[singing]
[music]
We [singing] will never see [music] the
air. We will never [singing] see the end
of your goodness.
[singing]
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness. [singing]
>> [music]
>> Sing in [music] our darkest hour
and in our darkest hour and on our
hardest day.
We do not have to be afraid. [singing]
For you will never leave.
We [singing] will not forsake
the promises that you have [singing]
made.
And [music] in our darkest hour and on
[singing] our hardest days,
we do not [music]
have to be afraid.
For you will never leave
and you will [singing] not forsake.
the promises that [singing] you have
made.
And [singing] we can [music] say
that we will [singing] never see the
end. We will never see the end.
[music] Oh, your goodness. [singing]
We will never see [singing and music]
the end. And we will never see the end
[music] of your goodness. [singing]
[music]
Never see [music and singing]
never see the end.
All right, we're going to dismiss our
kids to go to their kids classes now.
Um, you can meet your teachers over here
at these double doors. Thank you so much
to Meyn and Lily,
Kaylee,
and Jill.
doing good work there, mama.
Solidarity.
Some days are tough.
We're going to transition into prayers
of the people now. Um, and if this is
your first time with us, you can follow
along on the screens. We'll read the
sections in red aloud together. And we
will leave they sorry the slides people
are letting me know they may not be up
on the screens but um we'll leave space
in the middle of the prayer for you to
speak out a name or a situation that you
might be carrying into this room
tonight. Um we want to be a community
that holds each other up and believes
that God is with [music] us in both the
good and the bad times. Um and that's
why we participate in this tradition. So
if you guys would uh just pray along
with me.
Jesus, for this city of Saxi, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them. [music] We pray to you for
the good earth that you have given us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it. We pray to you for the old and the
sick. For the widow and the orphan, for
the injured and suffering, we pray to
you. For the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives, and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to [music] you
for those experiencing loss, loneliness,
and disconnection. And for those
struggling with mental and emotional
health, we pray [music] to you, Lord. We
know that you love us and that you hear
us. So we lift these names and
situations up to you.
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence.
Amen.
You meet me on the mountain [singing]
top.
You see me in the valley low.
There is no [singing] home without you
here.
And I find you in [singing] the crowded
thoughts.
You quiet all the question [singing]
marks.
There is no space your love won't
[singing] fill.
I'll trade [singing] all of my fear for
peace of mind.
All my heaviness [singing]
for burdens light.
This [singing]
will [music] be my song.
You are always good. [singing]
I'll sing [music] it all day long.
You [singing] are always good.
When [music] the [singing] day is
through,
I [singing] am left with you.
Are all [singing]
you are all [singing]
[music] good.
[music]
I set my eyes on perfect faith.
You'll finish [music] what you start in
me.
My [singing] heart will be an offering.
[music]
>> Trade [singing] all of my fear for
peace of mind.
You took complete [singing]
my [music] burdens light.
This will [music] be my song. [singing]
You are always [music]
good.
Sing [singing] it all day long.
You [music and singing] are always good.
>> [music]
>> When the [singing]
day is through,
I am [singing and music] left with you.
Are all
you [music and singing]
are
always
every
me [singing]
you're singing [music] back to me.
You're singing back every [singing]
[music]
me.
You're singing [singing] back to me.
You're singing [music]
back every
me. [singing]
You're singing back to me. You're
singing [music and singing]
back every
me. [singing]
You're singing back to me. No singing
back. Traded [singing]
all my fear for peace of [music] mind.
[music] You [singing] took heaviness
my burdens
light.
This [music] will be my [singing] song.
You are [music] always good.
Sing it [singing]
all [music]
day long.
You [singing] are
good.
>> When the [singing and music] day is
through,
I am [singing] left with you.
are
always
you are
good.
I'm no [singing]
longer
a slave
to fear.
And I am a child
of God.
I'm no longer [music and singing]
a slave
to fear.
I am am a child [singing]
of God.
[singing]
You unravel me [singing]
with a meloy.
You surround me with [singing] a song
of deliverance [singing]
from my enemies.
Till [singing] all my fears are [music]
gone. I'm no longer and I'm no longer
[singing]
a slave to fear.
No, I [music] am a child [singing] of
God.
I'm [music] no longer a slave [singing]
to fear.
[music]
>> No, I [singing] am a child of God.
From my [singing and music] mother's
womb,
you have chosen me.
Your love has called [singing and music]
my name
and I've been born again [singing]
into your [music] family.
Your blood flows [music and singing]
through my veins
and I'm no longer [singing and music]
slain to fear.
And I [singing] am [music]
a child of God.
I'm [music] no longer [singing]
a slave to fear.
[music] And I [singing] am a child of
God.
You split the sea so I could walk right
[singing] through it. My fears are
[music] drowned in perfect [singing]
love.
[music]
>> You rescued [singing]
me so I could stand and sing. I am a
child [singing]
of God. [music]
>> Let's sing that one more time. You split
and you split [music and singing] the
sea so I could walk right through it. My
fears [singing] are drown in perfect
love.
[music]
>> You [singing] rescued me so I could
stand and sing.
I [singing] am a [music] child of God.
I am a child of God. [music and singing]
I am a child [singing]
of God.
And I'm [singing and music] no longer
a slave to fear.
And I am a child [singing]
of God.
I'm no [music and singing] longer
a slave
to fear.
I [singing] am a child
of God.
God, we sink ourselves into [music] that
truth tonight.
That we can approach your throne with
boldness [music] and courage, knowing
that you are with us each step of the
way. That we can come before a God
[music] because he is a God of love
and there is no fear in perfect love.
You are with us.
You are for us.
You are standing in the gap,
God. where we feel loss and lack. I pray
that [music] you would come with your
sweet mercy,
that you would make up the difference,
God,
where there has been confusion and
darkness, where there has [music] been
loneliness and isolation, where there
has been division and hurt.
God, would your spirit come and heal and
renew and restore? [music]
God, would our hearts be open to your
work? Would we be like [music] good soil
who takes in the seed and allows it to
grow?
God, would you soften us?
Would you make us [music] sensitive to
your voice,
God? Would we have so much love
overflowing in our lives that it pours
out to the community around us, to the
people in our lives, our families,
our friends,
our church, our cities?
God, would we be full of you?
And would it make a difference?
We trust you to continue doing your
thing in our life.
And it's in Jesus name that we pray all
these things. Amen.
All right. Would you turn to the
neighbors beside you and say, "The peace
of Christ be with you." And then you may
be seated.
Grace and peace.
It is so good to be with you all. So, so
good. My name is Brett and uh my
pronouns are he, him, and yeah, it's a
joy joy to welcome you uh into this
space and as always that includes those
joining us online. y'all are not
forgotten and uh glad you're with us and
uh especially anyone here tonight who is
new. Thank you so much for you know
having the courage to come through those
doors. It can um it can be uh a lot you
know [laughter] and especially depending
on church history and stories and you
know people a lot of times it's I'll
just say it's the rare person who comes
through the doors of the table and it's
kind of like no no baggage with church
whatsoever just uh feeling feeling great
about this you know so um [laughter] so
we're just yeah we're really glad that
you're that you're here. I also want to
name um there's you know I think a
heaviness for a lot of us uh over the uh
the shooting and uh I shooting in
Minneapolis this week. It's just
incredibly heavy. Honestly, I was
tracking it via like stories. You know,
it's quite different to like read
headlines and kind of like read a you
know it was only about maybe two hours
ago or so that I jumped on like saw the
videos. Um, so there might be, you know,
quite a uh I don't know, just I don't
know how everyone's processing it and
such, but it's um I mean just it's just
incredibly disturbing. If you've been
around the table, you know, I'm really
um not one to like really, you know,
always be jumping on a political thing
or, you know, making some sort of rant
against people. That's it's not all my
heart. Um, but I just think there's, you
know, there's there's things that are
like um disturbing and uh and issues and
uh and there's a time for uh you know,
followers of Christ to discern like
what's God what's God calling us to do?
You know, I mean, what does it what does
it look like um for for us to pursue
justice, you know, and to to be in tune
with God's heart in this moment? And uh
and so I know, you know, that will look
a little different for for each of us.
um even just a few weeks ago was that um
that was maybe just before Christmas we
were talking about people you know
discerning what kind of season they're
in and is it a season of kind of
listening discerning is it a season of
kind of speaking out and speaking up and
you know so I think that'll it'll look
different ways I'm sure uh some of you
probably already been to a protest you
know others maybe doing something
different um but I just want to kind of
put that out there that I just know
there's you know it's a it's it's a
thing going on you know and a lot of us
are pretty uh heavy-hearted as we uh we
come in here tonight. Um, and at the
same time, it is beautiful to be
together, you know, and to have uh hope,
hope of Christ, hope of community and
love and uh and ultimately I don't I
don't want us to ever slip into that
despair, you know, but to to keep a
posture of like a an kind of an
openheartedness um towards God, towards
each other. Um and uh yeah, and and who
knows what God could do with us, among
us as we uh keep that heart kind of
posture. So, um, yeah. So, we've, if
you've, uh, been around the table, too,
you know, um, we're we do different
types of series. So, we're going to be
jumping into a a totally, um, new series
tonight. And we do this, it looks
different, you know, different ways.
Like sometimes we'll do like a topical
series, sometimes it will be um, uh,
kind of we'll join the church calendar.
And, uh, at other times we'll go through
like a book of the Bible. And so, uh,
that's what we're doing in this um, in
this series. We're going through the
book of First John and uh so we're going
to spend five weeks on this. So it's uh
the the series is titled No Fear in
Love, a study of First John. And uh so I
want to start um sorry, I'm hearing some
feedback, so I'm going to back up here a
little bit. Um I want to start with uh
just giving a little bit of kind of some
of the background uh on this book. And
uh so in terms of the author, it was
written um either by John the Apostle uh
possibly an associate of John or a
church leader in John's tradition. And
uh if you read the text closely, you can
tell it has like a lot of similarities
with uh the Gospel of John, you know,
like the language of like abiding in
God's love and uh the the truth and um
uh the you know, kind of these themes of
like light and darkness and all that,
which we'll get into some tonight. So
you there's it's enough that it's like
it does seem to be probably written by
the um the apostle John or someone very
close to him. Some scholars speculate
maybe he like wrote the book of it and
then maybe someone edited it later. Um
so the reason they think that is because
of how late the book was written which
we'll get to in just uh in just a
moment. So the audience um so the letter
it seems to be written to a church uh or
maybe a collection of house churches
likely again ones probably started by
the apostle John. Um the date so most
scholars place the writing of this
sometime around like 85 to 100 CE. So
like 5060 years or so uh after the
resurrection ascension of Jesus and they
so it's a later book for in terms of New
Testament standards. you you think 56
years after Christ like it's it's a
while you know uh enough for someone to
grow quite old which is why some
scholars wonder like well did John write
it or is it like edited later or
something you know because that's he
must have been quite elderly if he was
writing this you know which is possible
he maybe he was um now the reason they
say this isn't because there's some like
you know historical reference in the
book that like very clearly places it
like ah this must be exactly 50 years
after Jesus you know it's not that uh
it's more like you can tell as you read
it that the theology is it's like very
developed and uh and it no the whole
discussion of the book it no longer
seems to be kind of revolving around
early Christians relationship to Judaism
and so that's always like a clue for
scholars of like this must have been
later because you can imagine like right
Jesus was Jewish all the early you know
apostles are Jewish like all the
earliest Christians at very first or
close to most of them are Jewish you
know so like so the apostle Paul for
example His books are some of the
earliest written in the New Testament.
Actually written before the gospels,
which is interesting thing. We often
just think Matthew, Mark, Luke, John,
well, those came first because the first
in the New Testament, but no, is
actually Paul's writings are the
earliest we have. And you can see where
he himself is Jewish. He's really
wrestling with like, you know, temple
Judaism and what does this mean? the
implications of Jesus being Messiah is
you come to John both honestly as gospel
and but especially this book that is
like not on the radar.
So on the one hand it does make it quite
um I don't know relevant for kind of
modern readers in the sense of if you've
you know as I think many of us here most
of us probably are you know gentile like
non-Jewish. So I don't know how those
parts of the Bible strike us maybe as
like a little bit like I don't know how
much I can relate to you know the the
pathos of what Paul's feeling about the
temple and so you know it's kind of like
cool cool you know for him. Um, and so
it is it's interesting and maybe helpful
in his own way that John, you know,
isn't there. Uh, he's he's kind of uh
wrestling with some different things
that I think are um quite uh quite
relatable. So, you know, that's in other
words, it's kind of very textual
evidence of like a later date. Um, but
it is quite speculative. So, I don't
take personally like a strong stand on,
you know, like there's no way John wrote
this book or no, no, it's very possible,
but if he did, he was probably um much
older in his life. So, okay. So, that's
some of the background. Um, so with that
in mind, let's jump in to our message
today, which is titled No Darkness at
All. And our primary scripture is 1 John
1 1-5. So here we are right at the like
literally the opening words of the of
the book. And I'm going to be reading
from the message, which is a modern
paraphrase of the Bible. says this,
"From the very first day we were there,
taking it all in, we heard it with our
own ears, saw it with our own eyes,
verified it with our own hands, the word
of life appeared right before our eyes.
We saw it happen. And now we're telling
you in most sober pros that what we
witnessed was incredibly this. The
infinite life of God himself took shape
before us.
We saw it and we heard it and now we're
telling you so you can experience it
along with us. This experience of
communion with the father and his son
Jesus Christ. Our motive for writing is
simply this. We want you to enjoy this
too. Your joy will double our joy. This
in essence is the message we heard from
Christ and are passing on to you. God is
light,
pure light.
There is not a trace of darkness in him.
So, I am uh I'm now solidly in midlife.
And so, uh in keeping with my my
station, as of July, I've taken up golf.
I know it's not cool, but what can I do,
you know? 41. I just can't I can't play
ultimate frisbee anymore. I can't hang
with those 25 year olds all running in
circles around me. I haven't been able
to hang with them for a decade, you
know. So, I was like, I need a new uh
something new, you know, and uh so golf
it is. And uh one of the one of the kind
of weird things about golf is,
you know, especially if you're playing
in like the peak season. Um but most of
the time like they want to make as much
money as possible. So, you know, you
play in groups of four, which means
unless you're playing with like three
buddies or something, you know, you just
get paired with like random people. So
over the last you know six, seven months
or whatever it's been I have met some of
the most interesting people uh just
fascinate and there we are spending like
four hours together you know what I mean
like it's a while um and I mean it's
mostly been a delight uh sometimes not
so much but mostly and uh there was this
one gentleman uh I met his name was Todd
and uh Todd you know Todd was a nice guy
uh I could tell I don't know what I
could tell he was a Christian. Not sure
how, but I could just tell.
And maybe it was the lack of curse
words. Uh, you know, I don't know. Like,
I'm not sure. I was just like picking up
on something. [laughter]
And, uh, so on the, uh, kind of the back
nine, it was just me and him. Some
people had been playing with us left.
And so, it was just us. And so, I asked
him, I was like, Todd, are you a are you
a churchgoer?
And he said, I am. How could you tell?
And I said, "I'm not sure, but I can
tell." And he said, "How about you?"
Now, this is a key, this is a key
question, uh, as you can imagine for
someone in my world, my profession,
such. Um,
and I thought I mean, I considered just
lying maybe because I just don't want to
get into it all, you know, but no, I
mean, no, it's because then if it comes
out, you know, oh, what do you do for
work? You know what I mean? And it's,
oh, oh, you don't go to church. Okay, I
got to, you know, so I'm just, okay, I'm
just going to tell the truth. So I was
like, yeah, I am. And uh, in fact, you
know, I'm a I'm a pastor of a a local
kind of, you know, liberal kind of
progressive church here in Saxy, Texas.
I said this in my most kind of relaxed,
breezy, unassuming way possible.
um you know and uh he said,
"Oh
well, we are going to have some very
interesting conversations."
And inwardly I was just, "Oh my god."
And he said, "Uh you see, I am a
conservative Presbyterian."
And in that moment inwardly I groaned
because I knew he was like absolutely
right. Um I like I mean so much of my
theology is done sort of on the opposite
side of conservative. Now just I'm not
like picking on all president like the
reformed tradition as a whole like Carl
Bart and others I'm a fan like there's
like a kind of a progressive version of
the reformed theology. There's like a
lot good good going on there. Um but the
conservative strand the strand that's
just like John Calvin's the freaking
best and all you know that whole strand
I don't know. I just can't I can't do
it. I would I I this will sound
hyperbolic um but you'll see in a bit
why I actually mean this. I I would
probably become an atheist before I
would um adopt that theology. That
sounds I'm not even trying to be mean.
I'm not I don't mean that as like some
subtle jab. I just mean it quite
literally like I would No, I'm not going
down that road. And uh so you know, of
course, I mean, I didn't say any of
this. I didn't say any of this. You know
what I mean? It was just quiet and uh
I stayed silent. But Todd, he was like
he was young, you know, and uh he was
like antsy. I could tell he was anxious
and he started to press me. And uh on
hole number 10, he said, "What do you
what do you mean, you know,
progressive?"
Right? And I was like, uh, I mean, I
just I I mean, in the more kind of
cultural sense, you know, broadly,
uh, like, you know, uh, for example, we
believe women can and should be leaders
in the church. We we, you know, believe
LGBTQ folks should be fully included in
life, of the church. No, no
discriminator, anything like that. You
know, just, um, in other words, uh, you
know, it's not like it's not a sin to be
gay or trans or, you know, whatever. I
just, and again, I'm trying to keep this
like as chill as I can. I'm not trying
to attack or like, you know, and uh
I said it in that with that tone. It
just it didn't work. I could tell Todd
was bothered. And he said, "What about
the Bible, though? I mean, we can't just
make up what we want to be true. We have
to be faithful, don't we? We have to be
faithful to God's word first and
foremost. Don't you agree?"
And I said, um,
well, I mean, yes and no. I mean, in
short, no. I I mean, I think Christ is
the word, right? And, uh, but when it
comes to the Bible, no, I'm I'm not an
inherentist, Todd. I said, I don't think
it's as simple as, you know, well, the
Bible says it and that settles it. I I
think uh in ways the you can look at if
you read the Bible cover to cover, you
can see the theology kind of evolving.
Um I think uh the Bible is in very much
in at points in tension with itself. I
think at times it testifies beautifully
to the heart and word of God who is
first and foremost Jesus Christ and at
other times uh it does not. I said for
example when it advocate advocates for
violence against LGBTQ people um or says
you know God told his people they could
go forth and commit genocide in his
name. you know, I said, I think this is
a this is a theological disaster, you
know, and uh and then echoing first
John, I said, um I believe, you know,
God is love and light.
And then very I mean it was clever.
Well, one thing about the reformed
tradition, it is very um like they
highly value theological education,
which is something why I do resonate
with some of that tradition or parts of
me. They Todd knew his stuff, you know.
Todd said, 'I agree that God is love,
but isn't it up to God to define what
love looks like?
It's an interesting
insight here. I knew where he's coming
from on this. Um, this is it goes by
different names. There's it's called
theological volunteerism or divine
command theory. And uh it basically
holds that an act is moral not because
of its consequences on human flourishing
or because the nature of revelation of
you know Jesus Christ um or anything in
its inherent nature. A moral act is good
because of its inherent nature. None
none of that. Um instead merely it's
it's good merely by virtue of its being
you know supposedly commanded by God. In
other words, someone could say like yes
God is light and in him there is no
darkness at all. Ah, but the light does
not correspond
to what we as humans might intuitively
call the light. See, the good, they
would say, is whatever God commands. The
light is whatever God says it is, even
if it strikes you as evil
or wrong. Which means sometimes
genocide, violence against LGBTQ people,
murder really are the light.
Goodness, they would say, can look like
God's people killing a child as long as
God commanded them to do it.
So yes, you know, God is light. They
would say, "But the light may be what
you would call darkness, [snorts] but
it's not because it's commanded by God,
and God defines the light."
I hate this. This is why I said I would
have been an atheist before. I honestly
I feel like this is absolute jet fuel
for atheism. Like it's just like pouring
on their life. Like an atheist just
begging for a Christian to take this
stance like please, please do it. I
mean, it's just like perfect because now
it becomes a kind of moral
stance. You mean [snorts] a kind of
protest atheism, which I honestly do
think is about the really most powerful
atheism is a kind of moral protest. If
that's who God is, then I don't want
anything to do with that God who who
advocates for evil and injustice and
hatred and violence and bigotry, and I
want nothing to do with that. So, I'm
separating myself from that. And who's
with me? You know what I mean? That's a
powerful I'm like
[laughter]
there's something to that. Right.
Yeah. Now I am thankfully
[laughter]
that view uh which I'm sorry to say it
did become quite popular among early
Protestant reformers like Martin Luther,
John Calvin, which is why the very
conservative strains of those traditions
still are kind of like doubling down,
you know? And I'm like don't double down
on the worst of the tradition. You know
what I mean? Like there's other parts of
tradition that are beautiful, but
whatever. We just feel the need to
double down, you know? So um but that's
not the classical Christian
understanding. So the classical
Christian view that goes back earlier
into like Catholicism, Eastern Orthodox
and other wings of it um like Gregory
Nissa, even Augustine and some others um
they would say like no no no no no no we
know the difference between love and
hatred.
You know, [laughter] we know the
difference between goodness and evil
because God is literally the good
itself. God is life and light and love
and beauty and we don't love
God because God is all powerful and
whatever God decrees goes you know like
some abusive parent.
No
the like that kind of God could be
feared
but never loved.
Right? We know they would say what
flourishing and health and life and love
look like. And we love and we worship
God because God is the source of all of
these things. In other words, I I don't
worship God because the Bible commands
it, right? I worship because I'm drawn
by the source of all goodness, by the
beauty of the light.
In essence, it's not about fear kind of
pushing, right? Commanding.
It's what is it? It's love and it's
drawing.
It's it's calling. I'm lured. I'm
beckoned by a vision of flourishing.
Not just for myself, but like all
humanity, all creations
flourishing. I'm wooed by the source of
all compassion and integrity and beauty.
And so, no, genocide is not okay as long
as it's willed by God. Because God is
life.
God is light and beauty and truth and
goodness, not death, cruelty, hatred,
bigotry, and violence.
A kind of analogy here might be uh if
someone said to us, well, you see, my
spouse loves me and that's how I know
that their abuse of me is love.
We would just be like what? Right? Like
no, no, no, no, no. You are gravely
confused here. Right? Uh and why is
that? Because we already know love has a
form. It has a shape. It has a
character.
And you know some of that form like we
get from our experience. You know the
the tenderness of a parent or a
grandparent or a partner or someone who
loved us beautifully and well.
But as Christians we can actually go
even further than that, right? Because
it's not only a kind of moral intuition
born from, you know, experience and the
the light and goodness of God within
each and every one of us.
So, by now we're on like hole number 13
and uh I've explained some of the above
to Todd and he is growing frustrated
with me, more frustrated by the minute
I'm not agreeing with him and he doesn't
like it and he says, "Uh, God, but but
if it's if it's not as simple as like,
look, you can trust the Bible." Well,
then
what on earth are we basing our view of
the good and such on? And I said, Todd,
we are Christians.
It is based on Jesus Christ.
The four gospels. That's where we learn
the shape, the form, the way of love.
And only then can we read the rest of
the Bible with wisdom.
And I I would say to, you know, all of
you tonight, I get like some of these
terms, you know, can sound a bit, I
don't know, abstract, you know, goodness
or the good, beauty, truth, justice, you
know, the light. Uh and you might even
wonder how but like who defines you know
those things you know even if we agree
like well yes love does not look like
genocide you know but but still like
what but who does define what love is or
justice or you know and such
and uh I I would say as Christians um
love looks like Jesus Christ
love looks like Jesus Christ breaking
bread
with sinners
looking after the lowly,
coming as the servant of all, being a
peacemaker,
hanging on a cross, and forgiving those
who put him there, showing up to the
disciples who abandoned him after the
resurrection
with not one word of condemnation.
And this is why John writes,
"From the very first day,
we were there
taking it all in. We heard it with our
own ears. We saw it with our own eyes.
We verified it with our own hands. The
word of life appeared right before our
very eyes. We saw it happen. And now
we're telling you in most sober pros
what we witnessed. God is light. pure
light. There's not a trace of darkness
in him.
So in closing, what uh you what does
this mean for like our own Christian
living and spiritual practice and such?
Uh I maybe say this to to learn the form
the character the nature of Christ the
Christ who is the embodiment literally
of the love of God we should first and
foremost immerse ourselves in as I said
earlier the four gospels Matthew Mark
Luke John in fact my suggestion would be
read to the gospels 10 to 20 times if
you're new to the Bible read through the
gospels 10 to 20 times before you
proceed to the rest of the New Testament
then read the New Testament 10 times,
then proceed to the rest of the Bible.
Recently, my youngest was like, he wants
to read the Bible. He's like, "Dad, I'm
so excited. I'm going to read." And I
was like, "Great." He's like, "Um, okay.
So, I'm going to start here. Looks like
this first book is Genesis." I was like,
"Nope." Starting with Matthew. He's
like, "What? We're starting in like the
middle of the book or, you know,
almost." And I was like, "Yes." And this
is why this this is why, right? Because
as we've named um you even the early
church did not read the Bible as a kind
of flat text where every verse is as
central as every other or every book is
as important as every other. No, no, no,
no. was the Gospels, then the New
Testament, then the Hebrew Bible. That
will allow the truth that God is light.
And in him there is no darkness at all
to sink in and give us the interpretive
key that then guides our reading of the
rest of scripture.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and
the Holy Spirit. Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held the loaf of
bread and he broke it and he said, "Take
it. Eat. This is my body. It's broken
for you." And then he held up a cup of
wine. He said, "Take this drink. It's my
blood. It's shed for you. Whenever you
eat this bread, whenever you drink this
cup, remember me." And so Christians for
thousands of years now have gathered at
the table to center again on Christ who
is the very word of God who is the light
and love of God. And so that's what we
do as we come forward to uh receive the
bread and the cup tonight. Uh we
practice what's called an open table
here. So uh if you you're here tonight
and you want to participate regardless
of your exact like theology or
denomination or whatever um you're
you're welcome to participate. if you
want to connect with Christ, you you
come on and um there's no uh you know
communion police waiting for you. You're
you're good. And uh and at the same
time, if you're in a place where you're
like you don't really want to
participate, that's okay, too. You know,
there's no no pressure. Um you should
know the red is wine, the white is grape
juice. And uh finally, you can just
partake whenever and however you'd like.
Some folks take immediately, some come
forward and kneel, some return to their
seats and kind of prayerfully take it
there. No one will lead you through the,
you know, exact moment of partaking of
the uh the elements. So this is the
table, not the church,
but of the Lord. And it's made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more. So come you who
have much faith and you who have little.
>> You who have been here often and you who
have not been here long. You who have
tried to follow and you who feel like
you failed. Come. Come because it's the
Lord Jesus himself who invites you and
it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here. Come to
the table.
>> [music]
>> Thank you, Hank [music] and Eden, for
serving us. Um, we're going to close
with a song tonight, and you're welcome
to just sit in your seats and, uh,
listen to these words and take them with
you into your week. Um, we do pray that
God's light would find each one of us.
Lost [singing] and
[music] weary traveler.
searching for [singing] the
way [music] to go.
Strangers, [singing]
heavy [music]
hearted
longing [singing] for some
one you know. [music]
May you find
[singing and music] the light.
a [music] light. [singing]
May you find
a light [singing]
[music] to guide you on.
>> [music]
>> There are
wey [singing and music] travelers
searching everywhere
[music] you go. [singing]
Searching,
every searching,
longing deeply
to [music and singing] be known.
May you [singing] find [music]
a light.
May you [music and singing] find
[music]
May you find
a light [music and singing]
to guide you on.
May you [singing and music] find
a light.
[music] May [singing] you find
May you [singing and music] find
a light
to guide [singing] you on.
Thank you so much.
I forgot to make an announcement
earlier. And what's funny is Maggie and
I had actually [music] had a
conversation about it before service,
but we are going to have a game night, a
board game night on January 23rd,
[music]
Friday night from 6:00 to 8:30.
A pasta bar will be provided and set up.
And we ask that you'll please bring your
favorite game and dessert to share.
So, we're looking forward to that.
Thank you so much for joining us this
evening.
If you are new, we would love for you to
fill out a visitor's card on the table
on your way out.
Generosity is a key aspect of life and
adoration of worship.
If you call the table home and would
like to give financially, you can scan
the [music] QR code
or go visit the table at t the
tabletx.org.
And if you call the table home and you
are interested in a meetup, you can scan
the QR code
and find out more about our meetups um
dates uh days and and [music] times and
locations that might work for you and
and meetups are a wonderful way for
fellowship.
So we would love to have you.
All right. I would like to send you off
on your week with [music] this
benediction.
You may hold your hands out in a posture
to receive
or just open your hearts to these words.
You are a child of God.
You
are a child of God.
This is true on your best day
and this is true on your worst day. So
as you go into your yet to to be
determined week with its highs and lows
and everything that's in between, go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved.
You are [music] worthy.
You are accepted
just as you are. and go
filled with God's Holy Spirit and the
desire to extend those same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with. Be blessed,
have a good week, and we hope to see you
back here next Sunday.
May you find
a light. [singing]
[singing]